welcome back to piers morgan on census
spice girl mel b has been a global star
for decades but had perhaps her biggest
honor yet last week when prince william
presented it with an mba at buckingham
palace she dedicated her honor to all
women affected by domestic violence and
i'm delighted to say mel b joins me now
mel how are you
hi
good to see you congratulations thank
you how are you you're looking very
tanned
is that makeup or is that your tam
it's actually just a bit of makeup but
it's fine i'll take the compliment i'll
take the win um we're talking a win
congratulations on your mbe what does
that mean to you to get an nba and be at
buckingham palace
i mean it's really surreal to be honest
and i don't take it personally to do
with me
it's for all the women that have been
through similar things to what i've been
through so you know it's just more about
raising awareness but to get an mbe for
it is just
kind of crazy i'm like why didn't spice
girls get an mb but
i mean to do it for the women and to do
it for what i'm doing it for is just
like
quite overwhelming it still hasn't
really sunk in because it was only like
a few days ago and are you are you a
monarchist i mean we've got this late
breaking news tonight that the queen's
going to miss the state opening of
parliament obviously a lot of concern
about our health generally right now as
we head towards the platinum jubilee and
amazing achievement are you a big
believer in the royal family the
monarchy i mean i'm a massive royalist
like me my mom my sister my dad all
about the royals but you know what i
mean the queen's been through so much
you know she's lost the love of her life
she's 96 years old so whatever she wants
to do she can do i mean she's the queen
so it's up to her and i kind of bow down
to that you got your uh gong from uh
prince william and a little dicky bird
tells me that yeah in your earlier life
as a rampant young spice girl before you
matured into a more sensible one that
you guys used to get helicopters down to
high grove and secretly have peanut
butter sandwich parties with william and
harry is that true
well let me just explain i mean we got
invited to highgrove many times and it
wasn't our helicopter it was their
helicopter they'd hire it for us and
pick us up and then we'd arrive on the
lawn it was quite fancy and well to do
and then there'd all be these posh
sandwiches and we'd be like we don't
really want cucumber and
sandwiches let's go in the kitchen and
make some bagels and some peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches and they loved it i
mean they're only young but it was
really nice to see william
again
you know i'm all grown up and i'm
getting my mbe and he literally had such
a long conversation with me i got a bit
embarrassed because you know the whole
protocol is you wait for william to kind
of talk to you before you speak and then
he ends the conversation but this
conversation was going on and on and on
and i was looking behind me i was like
there's so many people waiting to get
there mbt
half of the conversation i'll never tell
anybody because that's between me and
him but it was really kind of taken
aback how you know i'm a spice girl but
yeah i'm getting the mbe for
um raising awareness for domestic
violence and women that are in
vulnerable situations he was just asking
me about my book
about you know how i was how long i was
in the abusive relationship before he
really went quite deep and then he said
to me goes so who you here with
and obviously my mom's white with blonde
hair and when i'm with my mum she's over
there and he was like oh hello and my
mom went bright red and then the
conversation still carried on he was so
sweet and so
polite and respectful i was one that was
like okay i think we need to go now
and yeah about to do my curtsy and i
whisked off and i was just
i was just kind of in shock but so happy
and so delightful when you see mel when
you see
right when you you know having having
had these fun times at highgrove with
him and harry when they were like
inseparable brothers how do you feel
about the way that their relationship
has fractured so badly at the moment
well i mean that's just what the press
are saying nobody knows really what
happens behind closed doors you know
it's true i mean those brothers it is
unquestionably true so
they are they are i have three daughters
i mean they're brothers at the end of
the day i have three daughters and you
know
i'm closer to one child for this closer
to my middle child for that so
you just don't really know what kind of
dynamic happens behind closed doors like
when you saw the whole kind of furore go
down with you know exit when him and
harry and megan left the country and we
we had the first biracial member of the
royal family and everyone was so full of
hope about it all and so positive around
the wedding and then suddenly within 18
months it was all over and she gone you
come from a biracial uh background
yourself what did you make did you feel
sad that it ended so quickly and so
acrimoniously
uh well i don't really take what happens
in the media as the gospel truth you
know i was just happy that
um the monarchy was so accepting of
somebody of black and white descendant
you know because it's so
white and very british which i love the
wilds like i said so it was kind of
a shame that it got presented in the way
that it did but like i keep on saying
nobody knows what happened you know and
if one of my kids wants to go and live
in australia or new zealand or
israel you know i will always be
supportive you know finally well you've
done some great work on that no no
you've just
it's uncensored you can say what the
hell you like on this show the
the uh i know i can and i'm talking to
you remember
the issue of domestic violence you've
written so powerfully about and spoken
so powerfully about now being awarded
for your work in this area right now
there's this grizzly trial going on
about probably one of the worst toxic
marriages i think i've ever witnessed
between johnny depp and amber we've had
two trials now in the middle of the
second one
does this kind of thing actually is it
damaging to the cause that you're trying
to advance and promote
i mean this is such like as
a very sensitive topic for me because
it's so personal
but um
to me this trial is is so this case is
so not entertainment for me
and what i what i worry about is it's
gonna damage
you know future men or women coming
forward and making their own claims or
the justice system having doubt or not
believing because at the end of the day
you know we can't get away from the fact
that two women get killed every week in
this country by their former partner or
their current partner as opposed to 12
men a year so i have to kind of remind
myself that i'm glad that people are
aware of the situation which is an
epidemic of domestic violence and
coercive control and any form of abuse
but i also think
that to look at this case as
entertainment is damaging and that's why
i have not even looked at it at all by
the way i've been in colorado with ruby
wax filming for three weeks which is
another story
which has been amazing so to land back
in england on
sunday because i now live in leeds with
my mum
surrounded by nature um
it was really kind of it really
made me have like a lump in my throat to
think that this is televised because i
know when i went through all my stuff in
the us
i i actually had to like file court
papers to be to have a closed um
courtroom because otherwise tmz were
going to be allowed in and all these
different outlets and
cameras and filming and all that stuff
and luckily the judge granted me for it
to be a closed court so i do think it's
i mean i think it's incredibly sad
it's very squalid and it's very sad and
it's like it's like this awful toxic
relationship exploding in everyone's
yeah human nature the judge i don't
think you can blame the public or even
the media these two are at each other's
throats and they're doing it in public
everyone's going to have a view but i
agree with you the moment that crosses
into entertainment then i think it
devalues the issue that you've
campaigned so courageously for well i've
got to leave your entertainment with
your tan
what's going to do with my tan
are you living in l.a are you living
here now because you've got your new job
i know if you if you just want to spit
it out that you quite fancy the way i'm
looking at the moment just say it it's
fine
just get it off your chest
come on you've been mentioning my town
three times i'm doing this you look good
you've got good lighting thank you good
lighting a good little bit of a spritzer
going on
you're looking hot i miss you
let's have dinner soon we've had a lot
of fun over the years i would love to
catch up with you great to see you we
have you take care mel that was probably
uncensored i like it
bye
[Laughter]
uncensored i didn't swear
you were about to that's why i've had to
get rid of you great to talk to you
bye
i love melby